[Musique]
alors l'heure est aux célébration à
Taïwan ou séjour de fête nationale un
événement qui survient cette année dans
un contexte de vivre tension avec la
Chine Pékin affirme vouloir défendre sa
souveraineté sur cette île qu'elle
considère comme faisant partie de son
territoire notre correspondant en Asie
Philippe Leblanc est à Taipe une
délégation d'élus canadien participe à
ces festivités
[Musique]
ils sont arrivés dimanche matin donc
hier ils sont une délégation de cinq
parlementaires Bloc québécois par
sylvéral et Parti conservateur et il
participe à ces célébrations où il y a
un défilé militaire et où j'ai parlé à
certaines personnes qui assistent aux
célébrations et on me disait que c'est
important cette année encore plus que
l'habitude d'être ici sur place pour
célébrer la souveraineté l'indépendance
et la démocratie de Taïwan donc c'est
dans ce contexte là que la délégation
canadienne participe au célébration qui
commence et qui vont durer toute la
journée et après les festivités les élus
Canadiens vont devoir vous rencontrer
les politiciens locaux pour parler de
certains enjeux qui sont primordiaux
pour les deux pays
il y en a une rencontre bilatérale qui
est prévue demain avec la présidente
China et la délégation canadienne va
aussi aller visiter le parc
technologique de simchu c'est le cœur
mondial de la production de
semi-conducteur c'est micro puce qui
sont qui sont vraiment essentiels dans
tous les produits électroniques les
téléphones intelligents Taïwan produit
plus de 90% des puces technologiques de
de haut niveau donc on va aller visiter
tenter d'en savoir davantage on va
mettre l'accent aussi sur la sécurité à
Taïwan dans le détroit de Taïwan et dans
la région et ce n'est pas la seule
délégation d'élus qui sont qui est en
Asie cette semaine la ministre des
Affaires internationales des Affaires
étrangères Mélanie Joly se trouve en ce
moment en Corée du Sud elle va aller au
Japon aussi ça fait partie de ces
démarches dans le but des laborer la
stratégie Canada canadienne pour
l'Indo-Pacifique qui devrait être
publiée plus tard cette année donc on
sonne un momentum on sent l'importance
de la région de l'Asie du Sud-Ouest pour
le Canada cette semaine très bien
Philippe Leblanc a été fait merci
[Musique]